good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the noble tonight we'll hear
from guest author Darren's tell off
discussing his new book Hamilton Adams
Jefferson the politics of enlightenment
and the American Founding Deron is a
history teacher at City College and the
Graduate Center of the City University
of New York he also wrote the making of
an American thinking class intellectuals
and intelligentsia
in Puritan Massachusetts ladies and
gentlemen please welcome Darren Stella
[Applause]
thank you very much for that welcome and
thank you very much for for coming to
this event what I'd like to do is just
begin by saying a few words about what
I've tried to do with this book how I've
organized it and what I'm trying to
achieve and then tell you a little bit
about what I think some of the important
themes in it are and then we - two very
brief passages first let me begin by
saying the kind of approach I'm trying
to take in this book a lot of ink has
been spilled on founding fathers and on
founding studies and much of it is
excellent work what I've tried to add
that's different is to combine what is I
think by now a fairly well-known
political narrative with the
intellectual and social history which is
not always as present in popular history
but try to do it in such a way that it's
still engaging and still fresh and not
something that only an expert can can
have interest in probably the most
obvious question and explaining this
book is to begin with the title Hamilton
Adams Jefferson why these three people
in some sense it's an almost obvious
choice
between these three you have figures who
are at the center of every political
event in the early republic probably for
about 1765 up to the 1820s I mean these
are three figures who dominate the age
but I would argue that there's even a
more important reason they dominate that
age more so than probably anyone else
except for George Washington because
each is the representative leader of one
of the three distinctive regions that
made up America and that's something
that I think a lot of contemporaries now
don't necessarily appreciate that even
at the moment of the Revolution in the
early republic America was an extremely
diverse place diverse ethnically
religiously but also socially and
geographically and in a lot of ways what
made these figures so critical and
important was that they were the
recognized leaders of their regions I
mean John Adams was the quintessential
Yankee Alexander Hamilton was the
ultimate Gotha might you know the
fast-talking
well-dressed elegant man about Manhattan
and Thomas Jefferson was the Virginian
par excellence the Virginia's Squire
that you know of legend and so I thought
using these three figures would allow us
to see in part the differences that made
up America but also the other part of
the the title the politics of
enlightenment the way these three
figures appropriated a shared and common
cultural tradition and that's the part
of the history of ideas or intellectual
history that I really want I think is
critical and I want to bring to the fore
which is that the American nation was
founded at a particularly propitious
moment for political founding for
Constitution writing for early political
development and that was the
Enlightenment and because we've all
grown up with the Enlightenment it's so
obvious to us that we fail to appreciate
what an incredible impact it had and I
what I've tried to do at the very
beginning of the book and a very brief
introduction for those who haven't
looked at the Enlightenment for a while
is to just give you a general sense what
were the major issues if you have looked
at the Enlightenment recently feel free
to skip it but what I argue is that the
Enlightenment really is the beginning of
the cultural and intellectual
recognition of
identity it's the beginning of
essentially our world and our worldview
I mean by that that in the Arab era
before the Enlightenment the goal of
government if you were a classical
Republican was the production of
virtuous citizens if you were a devout
Christian it was piety but if you were
enlightened you wanted neither virtue or
piety per se you wanted the pursuit of
happiness and pleasure and it defined a
culture that was not meant to cohere
around one shared salvific goal or
shared political credo but rather a
culture that was meant to be pluralistic
and a politics that were meant to be
secular this was also the first cultural
moment when people looked at the
relationship between the present and the
past and said the present may not be
worse than the past
classical Republicans Protestants and
Catholics alike all agreed that the age
in which they lived was an age of
declension the great republics existed
in Roman Greece the strong time of
religion was the Apostolic fathers in
the early church the enlightened were
the first to say that the modern age is
not only different but better that
technology Commerce and science had
produced this wholly new concept called
progress and I think it's important that
these three figures brought that
cultural tradition to bear on the
founding of this country I would urge
that they did so in different ways
precisely because they came from
different backgrounds socially as well
as regionally they appropriated
different things from the Enlightenment
what Hamilton took from the
Enlightenment was essentially the
Scottish celebration of Commerce and
that was natural he lived on 57 Wall
Street he lived right next to the
exchange and when he thought about the
glories of modernity he thought about a
modern commercial age that created
social mobility
economic dynamism and powerful
government and for that reason what he
what he grew out of the Enlightenment
and brought to bear on our early
government was the goal of a strong
federal republic one that would have
powerful resources both in peace and in
war a realistic foreign policy based on
a very frank assessment of what was
possible and what was desirable a
realization that political rhetoric must
be bound by the dictum ought implies can
that you cannot embrace as a political
ideal something you don't have the
resources to accomplish you must be
realistic but more than anything
hamilton sought to build us to create a
strong federal government to promote one
of the central projects of the
Enlightenment which was economic
development and particularly in an
economic development that would produce
urbanization Commerce and manufacturers
in short Hamilton wanted to use the
federal government to make America look
like Manhattan to make it all look a lot
like New York Adams by contrast being
the great New England Yankee took a
different element from the Enlightenment
he certainly was aware of the elements
that Hamilton drew on they were in the
same party he backed almost all of that
Hamilton's agenda but Adams also
inherited the great Puritan legacy that
made up Yankees curtains were people who
were very animated by a concern to
interrogate their conscience and be
painstakingly honest they kept journals
to mark their spiritual progress while
Adams was not a Calvinist he was not a
Puritan but he was a kind of secularized
Puritan and he kept the journal to to
mark his own intellectual cultural
progress and what he took from the
Enlightenment or brought to the American
enlightenment and to our political
tradition I would argue is the New
England strain of skepticism of searing
self honesty and conscience and that
meant that in an age where Hamilton
celebrated capitalism is the solution to
all social problems Adams said
capitalism is probably the best system
we have
but it's no panacea and it will create
its own unfairness and injustice --is
where others celebrated at the rise of
the common man to power Adams who as a
common man himself said
the common man will be no more virtuous
than the elites and neither are to be
trusted that government of a Republican
nature and freedom will persist only so
long as no social group whether it's the
elite or the other people ever
controlled political dominance more than
anything uh he thought the way to
achieve that was through ornate checks
and balances and he was the first to
come up with the ornate scheme we know
of in our Federal Constitution he did in
1780 and that was really the central
part of what he took out of the
Enlightenment the fact that approving
statesmen always expects political
leaders ultimately to be knaves whether
they really are or not and that you
should plan for them to be a bit
dishonest Jefferson and when some ways
had the most transcendent role began in
many ways as the most enlightened of
these three figures it was deeply
immersed in it
and that was a real challenge for a
Virginian because the Enlightenment in
France in the Netherlands in England and
Scotland and in America celebrated the
modern commercial age and an age of free
labor which is exactly what you don't
find in Virginia it's a slave dominated
Society and Jefferson tried to enlighten
Virginia to bring to bear on it the the
learning that would help people
understand the need to abolish slavery
to promote manufacturers to create
commercial development to create a more
dynamic and educated society all three
of these figures entered the revolution
with high hopes and aspirations all
three of them found them dashed by
historical experience and that's one of
the other themes I want to stress that
American politics of enlightenment
reacted to the realistic phenomena of
fighting a Revolutionary War and of
creating a political order
and what Jefferson did really was create
a new kind of politics beginning in the
1780s I think he breaks with the
politics of enlightenment becomes
America's first great romantic visionary
he does this and notes on the state of
Virginia he does it in his
correspondence and he does it in his
political rhetoric in the 1790s where
men like Hamilton and Adams had come up
with a politics of programs we all want
to promote wealth let's use social
science to figure out what sorts of
political programs will promote the
greatest social wealth Jefferson came up
with a politics of principle where
political community would be created by
deeply shared ideological beliefs where
the Enlightenment had embraced urbanity
and and Commerce and manufacturers
Jefferson discovered the agrarian idle
that what enlightened authors had called
rustic simplicity and the way they
considered the country the land of bores
bumpkins and booby Squires Jefferson
invoked in agrarian idle which said
quite the opposite what life in the soil
is an honest life to life of virtue and
in a lot of ways he became the prose
poet of American politics I would stress
again that all three of these responded
to not only regional influences their
social backgrounds but also the
political history that they experienced
as revolutionaries and in fact I've
structured each of the chapters dealing
with them around first a brief character
portrait then a discussion of what were
their views at the time of the
Revolution and then each one has a
section called the turning how their
worldview changed as a result of their
experience of the American Revolution in
the war for independence then a
statement of their mature vision
Hamilton is the enlightened and
fulfilled Adams the Enlightenment
transcended he becomes a great gadfly
and Jefferson the politics of American
Romanticism and then I end with a very
brief statement of suggesting what their
legacies are both in their time and then
and what I'd like to do now is just read
two brief legacy statements one on Adams
and the other on Jefferson and then open
the floor for questions and comments and
discussion so let me begin with Adams
the legacy section is called monuments
will never be erected to me the legacy
of John Adams John Adams live 26 years
in retirement the first half were spent
fretting about his legacy throughout his
career he had courted unpopularity by
taking principled stands in opposition
to public opinion whether defending the
British soldiers charged in the Boston
Massacre denying the natural equality of
men decrying the excesses of the French
Revolution or making peace in opposition
to the war hawks in his own party Adams
took a peculiar pride in his posture as
an independent gadfly he fully expected
to alienate many of his countrymen by
these acts and it was in part that
expectation doesn't that made his
actions seem so heroic to himself faced
with the calumny of his contemporaries
he SABS his aching vanity with the hope
that posterity would recognize his
greatness in his retirement however he
began to lose faith in this hope history
would not vindicate him because history
itself was hopelessly corrupt I doubt
whether faithful history ever was or
ever can be written he complained to his
old friend Benjamin Rush his legacy was
in doubt for a man of Adams soaring
vanity and accomplishment
such a fate was unendurable what Adams
could not stomach it was a growing
suspicion that he was being robbed in
the public mind of credit for his
accomplishments by other less worthy
figures for two years he had labored in
the Continental Congress for
independence the one man most
responsible for its eventual adoption
yet his historical role had been
upstaged by quote the theatrical show of
the Declaration of Independence
Jefferson ran away with all the stage
effect of that
and all the glory of it you spent the
better part of a decade in vital
Diplomatic Service none of which could
compete with the popular image of
Franklin as America's great diplomatic
genius his thoughts on government were
eclipsed by pains common sense just as
his defense of the Constitution's and
discourses on Davila were dwarfed by the
Federalists Washington's administration
was already immortalized by what Adams
called
the impious idolatry to Washington and
Jefferson's will be quoted by
philosophers as a model of profound
wisdom his own by contrast will have no
character at all mausoleum statues
monuments will never be erected to me he
complained panegyric aroma answers will
never be written nor flattering oration
spoken to transmit me to posterity in
brilliant colors as ever
Adams vision proved depression he have
no monument or holiday to commemorate
him his face does not even appear on our
currency in the first dozen years of his
retirement Adams vainly struggled
against his fate in 1802 he began
working on his autobiography he got as
far as the beginning of a diplomatic
tenure when he abandoned the project in
1809 he commenced publication of a
series of essays and documents in the
Boston Patriot in defense of the
sampling of the quasi-war one of the
wisest most virtuous most successful and
most important actions of my life
humility was never a problem for John
Adams within a few years however his
interest flagged and he stopped writing
Adams never could tell his own story
lacking the ability to control his
emotions he often fell into tangential
asides of strident self-justification
and equally strident accusations of his
adversaries more than that he was simply
too honest to sing his own praises in a
sustained fashion I look so much like a
small boy in my own eyes he wrote to
rush that with all my vanity
I can't endure the sight of it
Adams's did at last find his path to
fame on January 1 1812 he resumed his
correspondence with Thomas Jefferson the
bitter election of 1800 had doused the
already flickering embers of their old
friendship jefferson considered Adams
and apostate to the revolutionary Creed
Adam saw The Virginian as a political
intriguer for years Benjamin Rush a
Philadelphia physician and mutual friend
from the days before independence have
been trying to reconcile the two old
comrades he considered the North and
South Poles of the American Revolution
renewed correspondence with Jefferson
would not only do great honor to Adams
Russia shorten it would afford him the
opportunity to examine the seeing the
business in which they had been engaged
and all the errors of opinion conduct
conduct into which they had fallen in
short it was a perfect venue for stating
his case to future generations at the
very outset of 1812 Adam sent Jefferson
as a friend to American manufacturers a
brief letter with two pieces of homespun
two volumes of his son's lectures on
rhetoric and oratory thus began the most
remarkable correspondence in American
political history perhaps the greatest
work of early American letters the Adams
Jefferson correspondence was clearly
written for posterity
both pretended otherwise Jefferson
feigned shocked that a printer has had
the effrontery to propose publication
Adams claimed indifference Jefferson's
letters he assured him
do you know dishonor while in his own
case my reputation has been so much the
support of the public for 50 years and
will be with posterity that I hold it a
bubble a gossamer that idles in the
wanton summer air nothing could have
been further from the truth each sought
to direct the correspondence into
channels that would best serve his
reputation
thus Jefferson resisted Adams subtle
attempts in the first year to broach
their political differences
Jefferson preferred to present himself
in a posture of serene retirement above
the fray of partisan political squabbles
Adams's would have none of it he fired
back a volatile letter stating his
political position and pointedly
demanded that you and I ought not to die
before we have explained ourselves to
each other
sensing his old friends desperate need
to speak his mind in the state his case
Jefferson relented and allowed himself
to be led on this epistolary excursion
by the bumptious Yankee he was in for a
wild ride in addition to discussing
politics past and present and history
ancient and modern Adams controlled
Jefferson in two debates on ethics
religion theology metaphysics
epistemology Indian Affairs Hindu
cosmology and literary criticism no set
of documents can match this
correspondence in revealing the minds of
these two men after breaking the ice
Adams dominated their ensuing
correspondence part of his dominance
came from sheer effort Adams wrote over
two-thirds of the roughly 160 letters
they exchanged Adams was also the better
epistolary stylist Jefferson's stately
and lofty missives seemed almost
pedantic in contrast to what Rush called
Adams elevated a nervous style where
Jefferson was ponderous and earnest
Adams was playful
humorous even mischievous Russian warned
Jefferson that some of his thoughts
Electrify me most of all however Ammon
Adams dominated the correspondence by
force of argument Jefferson may have had
more intellectual breadth than the older
Yankee but on those matters he cared
about Adams had a depth of knowledge and
insight that The Virginian could not
hope to match and since Jefferson
graciously allowed Adams to steer the
discourse Adams selected those topics he
was strongest at the correspondence of
Jefferson was a tonic for Adams frayed
self-esteem as his principal modern
biographer is noted he was no longer the
bitter vindictive man he had been when
he departed Washington Adams had
mellowed secure in the knowledge they
had last secured
legacy for posterity the correspondence
with Jefferson was his monument Alby at
a literary one it associated his name
with jad of that of Jefferson and served
to remind Americans of his contribution
to the two men's mighty collaboration in
securing independence in the Continental
Congress this association was only
strengthened by the fortuitous fact that
they both died on the same day July 4th
1826 the 50th anniversary of the
Declaration of Independence with
Jefferson and Washington he was now one
of the eternal heroes of 1776 although
primarily associated with American
independence and popular consciousness
Adams has had far more profound
if subtle legacies not the least of
these had been cultural Adams was the
first of a long line of Yankee gadfly's
men with a strong contrarian streak who
stood against the overwhelmingly
optimistic strain of American culture as
a youth Adams had been charged by his
friends Jonathan Sewell and Daniel
Lennard with a little capillary vein of
satire meandering about in my soul and
it broke out so strangely suddenly and
irregularly that it was impossible ever
to foresee when it would come and how it
would appear well that same vein of
satire can be found in the writings of
subsequent Yankee contrarians like
Herman Melville William Gaddis and
Thomas Pynchon their system novels mimic
Adams insufferably long-winded in
tangential style just as they share
Adams ironic vision that life and
history too close critic disclose
critical truths to which those living
and making history will ever be
oblivious this ironic and skeptical
screen in American thought first
exemplified by Adams has supplied the
National culture with what Frederick
Nietzsche called the intellectual
conscience curmudgeonly gadfly's like
Adams have kept our culture at least
minimally honest the truth is out there
Adams tells us if only we have the
courage to pursue it
John Adams greatest legacy however was
political the great apostle of balance
Adams constitutional musings were
predicated on his conviction that no
political party movement or leader was
immune to the corruptions of human
nature he did not deny the existence of
virtuous and disinterested political
leaders he simply insisted that they are
not enough in any age or any country to
fill all the necessary offices trust no
one was this Creed especially those
whose quote hypocritical pretense of
disinterestedness and public virtue were
set up to deceive the people and take
advantage of their ignorance and
credulity to protect the people from
such intriguers Adams championed your
innate system of checks and balances and
separation of powers that inform
American constitutional government in
the years since his death American
voters have seen these constitutional
checks and balances transformed by an
imperial presidency and an active
judiciary the direct election of
senators has reduced the difference
between the two branches of the
legislature to one of duration in office
instinctually the American people have
compensated by devising an electoral
strategy to achieve a dam Xion balance
the American penchant for divided
government unique among Western
democracies has served as an
extra-constitutional means of checking
political power what critics decry as
gridlock is in fact American government
working exactly as Adams desired
American voters divided power within the
federal government
precisely because like Adams they know
that neither party is entirely right or
disinterested they divide power because
they know that neither party has a
monopoly on virtue or can be completely
trusted state of eye power because they
know that the ensuing interminable
partisan strife checks the worst
excesses of the most powerful most
important they divide power because they
know as Adams
insisted that as long as neither party
achieved true dominance republican
government persists and with it our most
precious liberties this is john adams
greatest legacy all in all not bad for a
curmudgeon okay now I'd like to read
briefly the legacy of Thomas Jefferson
take care of me when dead the legacy of
Thomas Jefferson America's founding
fathers had played a pivotal role in
history the progenitors of the first
successful revolution in modern history
they assured in a new political epoch
that would transform public politics and
society in every corner of the world
they also knew that their contributions
would ultimately be judged by posterity
and it was that judgment that animated
their careers and informed their writing
more than any other generation of
American statement statesman the
founding fathers were obsessed with
their legacies Thomas Jefferson was no
exception in the last decade of his life
he was consumed with the need to set the
historical record straight perhaps even
more than his old friend John Adams
Jefferson consistently defended his
tenure as governor of Virginia and
rejected any attempts to question either
the centrality or the originality of his
Declaration of Independence in numerous
letters he denigrated his rivals such as
Patrick Henry and Alexander Hamilton and
stressed the critical importance of his
own contributions to the early republic
the year before the Missouri controversy
erupted he began composing his Annis a
survey of the political battles in the
1790s
three years later he commenced drafting
an autobiography both works presented
their author as a high man minded man of
principle both depicted his opponents as
dangerous ante Republican and
self-serving ultimately both were
abortive like Adams and his essays in
the Boston Patriot Jefferson was unable
to sustain the effort necessary
to complete his justification in his
final year return to his closest friend
and associate James Madison with one
last request
knowing the death was knocking at his
door he implored his fellow Virginian to
quote take care of me when dead he could
impose no greater burden in the years
after his death Jefferson's imprimatur
would be claimed by a broad range of
Americans northern workers hailed him as
the Democratic champion of the common
man southern slave owning planters paid
homage to his defense of states rights
both Jefferson Davis and Abraham Lincoln
invoked the Madal mantle of the sage of
Monticello as have Newt Gingrich and
Bill Clinton in our own day indeed no
other American Statesman's words have
been cited so often and for such
diametrically opposed purposes one
legacy however is incontestable Thomas
Jefferson created a visionary politics
of American Romanticism this politics of
principle transcended the mundane realm
of programs and policies and introduced
an idealistic often otherworldly
character into American political
discourse it is this visionary character
for more than the particular principles
Jefferson ascribed to that is his
greatest and most enduring contribution
to American life if soaring rhetoric and
romantic sensibilities transform the
politics of American of the American
nation since his day every major
political movement has needed some set
of transcendent principles to rally the
populace whether new nationalism or new
freedom new deal or new frontier Great
Society or mourning in America
Republicans and Democrats greens and
militiamen all wrapped their programs in
a rhetoric of glorious ideals and sacred
principles after Jefferson every
successful American politician has had
to evoke
the vision thing and all successful
political movements have deployed a
visionary rhetoric this Jefferson's
greatest legacy has been decidedly mixed
in its results the visionary character
of Jeffersonian political discourse has
often served to obscure the real
sufferings and in justices in American
society under patinas of glittering
principles and abstract ideals in his
own day the dogma of limited government
and states rights served to include any
meaningful national discourse about the
future of slavery in the early republic
just as his agrarian idle through a web
of romantic rhetoric over the
underdeveloped and crude character of
southern rural society in the years
after his retirement manifest destiny
would give divine sanction to a brutal
an occasionally genocidal program of
conquest and expansion Woodrow Wilson's
rhetorical inflation of the first world
war into a struggle for global democracy
human rights and an end to all future
wars was used to justify a draconian
suppression of dissent as was the
struggle
to defend freedom from the Menace of
global communist totalitarianism albeit
on a much smaller scale in the 1950s
even when it has not been used to cover
malevolent actions Jefferson's romantic
politics of principle has had a
disturbing effect some fear devotion to
abstract truths has animated some of the
most ferocious and canine partisanship
in our nation's history and it's
heightened ideological differences among
people whose practical differences might
have been easily negotiated perhaps most
insidious of all subscribing to some
transcendent vision has for many
Americans served as a proxy for actually
redressing the wrongs they purportedly
deplore maintaining an authentic
commitment to a virtuous sentiment has
also often been a means to claim a
self-righteous moral superiority that
solve the moral sensibilities of
concerned citizens without actually
helping the objects of their concern all
too often
Jefferson's politics at Prince
has allowed Americans to sin with a good
conscience it was so in his own day as
well there is however a far more
positive side to Jefferson's vizionary
legacy in times of national crisis his
romantic rhetoric has proved an
irreplaceable resource for rallying the
American people precisely because of its
power to mobilize public opinion the
federal government has rarely had to
resort to outright repression and force
in moments of national emergency but
more than that the politics of principle
has throughout our history been a source
of inspiration and justification for
those who have sought to force the
nation to live up to its transcendent
ideals
there's the resource has been especially
valuable to those who have been denied
full access to the benefits of American
life or who have struggled against some
justices since Jefferson's day it has
been impossible to dismiss the dream of
any reformer
however utopian a radical at simply on
American the gap between romantic
rhetoric and tangible realities has been
a constant spur of renewal forcing all
those who deploy it to live up to its
ideals the visionary politics of
principle that Jefferson created as thus
exerted an incessant pressure on the
nation's public life one that demands
the actualization of lofty goals and the
enactment of abstract principles the
visionary character of American
political discourse has sustained the
hopes of the disadvantaged and
maintained the faith of the American
people in their government and their
future Thomas Jefferson taught America
as a political entity to dream if he had
done nothing else in his long and
remarkable life he would still have
given us ample reason to take care of
him when dead thank you
[Applause]
any questions yeah a question over here
well one second respectively points of
these three wonderful what do you call
them founders leaders leaders okay let's
kind of think of a real good word in
relation to separation of search of
Education and church and state
excellent question really two questions
that one was their view of Education and
then what separation of church and state
all three of them favored public
education in fact Adams in his
constitution of 1784 Massachusetts which
is the only Revolutionary Constitution
that is still in operation they haven't
rewritten it I actually put in a clause
saying that the state of Massachusetts
should support universal public
education for all citizens and as well
as support higher education to college
and university level and the advancement
of scientific and cultural development
in you know things like historical
societies and he himself had helped
found the major scholarly society in new
england jefferson tried to get a system
of public education in place for
virginia it was unsuccessful it was part
of his frustration at the politics of
enlightenment he tried to bring it but
but at the political class the
leadership of Virginia would not put up
with it
Hamilton too favored public education in
some ways you could see why he would the
most he was the poorest of the three was
an illegitimate son who had gotten to
the United States from the kindness of
strangers basically and it was his
college education that made him what he
was now about the separation of church
and state certainly then the
Enlightenment core culture is secular
right secular humanism is the
Enlightenment is an Enlightenment
project
however it's a complicated question
because while the enlightening cells
were for the most part based or had
religious convictions that were less
than fully religiously Orthodox they had
great respect for the orthodoxy of the
masses so atoms themselves didn't
believe in that Jesus was the son of God
neither did Thomas Jefferson an
interesting fact
but Jefferson nonetheless remained the
vestry men in his church and supported
it and Adams continued to stick by the
Congregational churches although he was
in fact geologically a Unitarian but he
thought you know the people respect the
congregational beliefs and it's
important that they be respected so
their basic view was you know insofar as
the question becomes how do we make
sense of the first another they were
still politicians but also that was part
of the code of the Enlightenment the
Enlightenment was a very urbane and it
was a movement among a minority of
Americans and Europeans and they never
what they wanted was toleration for
their own perspective they didn't want
to impose their perspective on the rest
of society so as long as you let us be
you know heterodox were more than happy
to let you be Orthodox but neither of us
should be able to dictate our desires to
the political culture so in kind of a
neutrality I guess you'd say question
over here
what do you think was at the center of
the long-running dispute between Adams
and Jefferson other than Adams own
tortured personality and his
insecurities what else do you think
he'll play that dispute between the two
of them do you think that their
upbringing and Adams strong religious
background played a factor he thought he
was more moral than Jefferson
I have Adam certainly thought so well
let me first say that the issues you
raised which is his tortured personality
and his anxieties and insecurities did
have a lot to do with it
part of it was philosophical they really
looked at the world differently Adam as
I say was not particularly worth of Docs
but it was a secular Calvinist it didn't
believe in Calvinism but he did think
people are basically dangerous and
sinful and had to be watched carefully
and he didn't think he was an evil
himself an exception Jefferson was
filled with optimism about human nature
and Adams who was eight years older than
Jefferson and cared about him for a long
time like a younger brother thought you
know poor innocent Tom he'll just never
going to grow up he's never going to
realize he's going to be taking an
advantage of time and again and then
when they became political rivals he
discovered something which is the
Jefferson was brilliant and an amazing
political leader he also had the
remarkable ability to change his beliefs
with absolute sincerity when it was
convenient so that he could pass a
lighted test to Detective time and I
think he deeply cared about Adams but he
hired muckrakers to say horrible things
about him and he was able to say well I
didn't know they were going to say
horrible things although obviously did
that's all these guys did they were
hacks oh absolutely the the guide the
Nate at the time the Karl Rove of the
time or Carville whoever you want
was a guy by the name of James pump
James Callender and he wrote a book paid
for by Jefferson about Adams which he
called him hoary headed incendiary and
when Adams found out that Jefferson
wrote it he just could never forgive him
now the irony is Jefferson in his own
part didn't think he did anything wrong
because he didn't write the book
and well calendar went too far but Adams
you really were a little bit off
off-base and he figured that calendar if
he's extreme it's because of the purity
of his principles well he found that
later that Adams was kind of right about
this this sort of rhetoric because after
Jefferson beats him in the election
calendar says well I hope you're going
to give make me the postmaster of
Richmond and Jefferson no I'll give you
$10 go away and so he moves to Richmond
and says well I can do another expose I
hear there's a story that there's some
slaves who live in your house that look
just like you and that's how I know
about Sally Hemings he's the one who
broke that story so and you did a great
letter Abigail Adams writes to him and
says you know I'm really sorry that this
came out that couldn't happen to a nice
guy
question over here you all realize that
Adams had a ever get brace of
personality collision but he was one of
our great founding fathers and you made
a point earlier that when you think of
all the great tributes monuments
especially say Hamilton last year the
anniversary of the duel and but you see
nothing for Adams you see very little
mm-hmm and even commercial
commercially in commercially in LA in
the last two decades
Jefferson Hamilton there are so much in
the way of monuments and tributes and
again almost crass commercialization and
again very little towards Adams
unfortunately well I think Adams is
beginning to get his innings
you know David McCullough's biography
certainly brought him to public
attention as the Joe Ellis is fine
biography of him as well to be fair
Adams is a very strange character I mean
he's curmudgeonly
he's known to be incredibly vain and
difficult and irritable yet he's
extremely self-aware he knows he's vain
he knows he's curmudgeonly and it's a
real choir taste and once and I what
happens with scholars is once they
acquire the taste they all fall in
with atoms and that that's what Russia
told Jefferson if you store
corresponding with him you will love him
and Jefferson says the same thing to
matter Madison if you know him he's
crazy he's you know difficult but you'll
love him he's the most honest man
imaginable he doesn't have the kind of
personality that's likely he doesn't
have a face you'd put on the Mount
Rushmore right he's got mutton-chop
whiskers he's fat he's got no chin he's
bald
he you know had a horrible temper
Jefferson was his vice president told
tales of cabinet meetings where his
cabinet officers would disagree with him
and Adams of pull off his wig and throw
it on the ground left on stamping on it
and that's that's definitely Adams but
as they say it's an acquired taste and I
don't think he expected that a majority
of people would be taken with him but if
there's a small number of people who
appreciate his contribution in some ways
that's enough because I think people
privately know that his idea of trust no
one divided government and I don't trust
them as far as you can kick them it's
kind of true and so there's a certain
sense in which Americans are all
Jeffersonians were optimistic filled
with soaring hopes but there's a part of
it and the reason why this country keeps
going is mostly Jeffersonians in the
part in the back of our heads this is
yeah but be careful be prudent and and I
think that's that's a very real part of
our American political culture I think
it's a bends in when it's went nah I
think he's one of the reasons why the
Civil War started when you go back to
the Kentucky resolution his opinions of
the Missouri Compromise I mean he was
duplicitous
that just the way the Constitution was
written and what I really wanted to say
also is that when you're talking about
checks and balances I really think
that's revisionist history if you read
there's nothing in the constitution says
checks and balances and if you read all
the different writings of the founding
fathers
nothing does I think it's just people
want to say it is it's because it just
seems nice they really want this long
throwing legislative body they weren't
they wanted a weak presidency in
judiciary was this that's just the way
it was okay let me let me deal with
those two excellent points in sequence
first about Jefferson's dishonesty now
Joe Ellis has a great line you know
Jefferson anyone else would be dishonest
if they did what Jefferson did but
Jefferson has the unique ability to
believe what he's doing at every moment
and that's kind of true he's a lucky guy
he's you know a true believer who
believes in his own virtue and once in a
while we come across politicians like
that and they're they're remarkable they
can say one thing today in the next
thing tomorrow and pass a lie-detector
test
so I also I don't think you can quite
blame the Civil War on him he did not
act alone there was a political culture
and society yeah but I understand you
yes he said he had a very southern
policy and what was behind the politics
of principled Jeffersonian republicanism
was ultimately a very Pro southern
position there's no question of that
the other question about checks and
balances and the goal for a strong
legislature and a weak executive it's
very interesting in 1776 there's no
question that that's true you find that
in almost every state legislature and in
every new constitution and some they
don't even have any meaningful executive
at all and they have a unicameral
assembly like Pennsylvania in Vermont
there's one exception to that and that's
John Adams
he writes thoughts on government and he
uses the phrase checks and balances and
he puts it in a 17-8 Constitution from
Massachusetts where he gives he's the
first to do this he says we need an
independently elected executive with a
legislative veto and a Senate that is
elected on a different basis than the
house and an independent judiciary that
serves for life and can only be removed
by being impeached for high crimes and
misdemeanors and at the time that's
considered very kind of reactionary but
within about seven or eight years guys
like Madison and J and Hamilton meet in
Philadelphia and come up with the exact
same arguments and in his written his
justification for American
constitutionalism this really long two
volume book called defense of the
American constitutions
Adams's uses that phrase checks and
balances over and over again in a letter
to to Jefferson Jefferson writes to him
and says you know America will remain
free as long as the people are virtuous
and as long as they're farmers they'll
be virtuous and Adams writes back and
says no checks and balances Jefferson
checks and balances
that's how long they'll stay free so
that's part of the reason he wasn't so
loved is because remember with the
principle of checks and balance why that
was controversial when you got strong
legislators it was because the
legislators were the voice of the people
right and the executive was something
else the voice of the elite so to say
checks and balances meant that we can't
trust the people that there has to be
something to check their will and that
atom consists of being a commoner
himself he said of course a little
better than anybody else so for that
reason he's not the most popular but I I
do think checks and balances is central
to American constitutionalism question
back here what do you think each of your
subjects would say or believe about the
current probably minority movement in
jurisprudence original intent of
interpreting the Constitution according
to the original intent of the founders
and I guess the other side of that just
to pontificate for two seconds would be
the Constitution as a living document
with a number of Rights
to be applied to the new age as with the
principles inherent in it well it's an
excellent question and it's it's
complicated because they didn't use that
phrase at the time the first I actually
talked about original intent was Madison
and anytime you talk about original
intent the problem is whose intent the
people who wrote it well it was written
by committees that people who hated each
other and didn't agree with all
compromises should it be the intent of
the the people who called for the
convention well they had different views
Madison said it should be the views of
the
we ratified it well they had different
views so you original tense a bit of a
red herring the way it was discussed at
the time was should you have a script
literal reading of the Constitution or a
broad and expansive one and districtís
closest thing they had to the original
intent argument from that was
Jefferson's position he said read the
Constitution as saying thou thou shalt
if it says thou thou shalt do something
you can do it but if it doesn't you
can't so if the Constitution doesn't
specifically say you can do something
then you can't do it
Hamilton took the opposite position he
said if the Constitution doesn't say you
read it that shalt not if it doesn't say
I can't do something then I can do it
and they had intense arguments on a
whole host of issues most prominently
being the Bank of the United States
Hamilton wanted to charter a bank to
monetize the debt and it's super
complicated explained in the book but
basically wanted to create the Federal
Reserve System and he did and I worked
brilliantly it created money for the
nation and solve their debt problem and
Jefferson acknowledged it would be
useful but he said there's nothing in
the Constitution that says anything
about creating banks so in a strict
interpretation all powers in the 10th
court of the 10th amendment not given to
the federal government are reserved to
the states so you can't do it and
Hamilton's answer always was on
everything that he'd fight with
Jefferson about general welfare Clause
Constitution says I have the power to do
whatever is for the general welfare
certainly creating currency and ending a
depression and the general welfare
doesn't specifically say I can't make a
bank so common sense says we can find
the rights we need if we just apply
reasonable it was also a different way
of thinking about the Constitution
Jefferson thought of it as in a way the
way original intent jurists do now is a
bedrock document that lies out clearly
the frame of government Hamilton said
look it's a good first guess it gives us
some broad outlines
but the details are all going to be made
up in the in practice and precedent
another change what what would their
view beyond traditional review which
came about as a result of Marbury vs.
Madison great question
and a bit complicated I don't know what
Adams you was or would have been I
suspect he would have been okay with it
he wanted a very strong judiciary
Jefferson never accepted judicial review
even after Marbury vs. Madison it's
settled nothing in his mind he called
those people consolidations and he
wanted to impeach the Supreme Court
justices did actually teach some of them
he later on in his life when the
Marshall court continued to expand the
courts provenance said you know what we
should limit them to 6-year term of
office and make it renewable but
Congress and ultimately he said the real
judicial constitutional review is not
done by the Supreme Court it's done by
the states which is what he did with the
Kentucky resolutions each state judges
whether acts are constitutional and if
they don't like them just nullify them
repeal them that the court is has no
more authority over that than any other
branch Hamilton be exact again they're
the perfect polarity exact opposite
Hamilton is probably the the true author
of judicial review
he writes into the Federalist Papers now
it's not necessarily adopted in the
early courts before Marshall shows up
but he clearly has that in mind in fact
there's a famed quote that John Marshall
tells the judge story on the Supreme
Court
he said when it came to jurisprudence I
was a mere school child Alexander
Hamilton was my teacher Hamilton was the
most distinguished member of the New
York Bar when he studied his real New
Yorker and he's a guy who you know
decides he wants to get a law degree
takes Jefferson seven years to do his
reading to get his law degree Adams
takes two year takes Hamilton six months
and he comes up with and just a
prodigious New York in love with a
different way of doing it too
instead of studying coke he decides he's
going to write up his own book of
procedures of the actual procedures that
are used in courts and when he's done it
becomes the standard study guide for the
bar exam in New York for a hundred years
I mean just change the way people study
the law but he's very big on judiciary
view Hamilton is one of those guys who
believes in part because he comes from
the very bottom of society and is an
abolitionist that the courts are the
ones who are really going to defend our
liberties and ultimately popular
government isn't what we mean by freedom
it's important what's more important is
individual freedom and liberty and
that's going to come from the courts
[Music]
yeah I'll leave time for one more
question apparently
I just wonder how how did you choose to
leave Franklin out of this great group
um it's a very very interesting question
I needed one guy to represent the
mid-atlantic and Franklin was a live
option except that Franklin dies before
the the founding period proper he dies
before the 1790s
besides Franklin's gotten a lot of ink
and I must say I teach up at City
College and the grain which is
Hamilton's
estate is about a block and a half from
my office I've never seen anyone visited
and he's really the bastard of the
founding fathers and it's it's tragic
because I think in in terms of the
politics of the early republic of the
constitutional federal government he's
much more important than franklinís I
mean he's just